I mean science is really it's the
plumbing level of reality it doesn't
catch you know the integrated nature of
language the evolution of fairytale the
dynamics of love affairs the
quintessence of genius these are the
things that as human beings structure
and constellated guide and inform our
world and science has nothing to say
about these things mathematics on the
other hand is like the bedrock
celebration of these things it empowers
intuition it discovers intuition to be
the most powerful epistemic tool that we
have more powerful than induction more
powerful than deductions intuition is
the unifying of experience into a
gestalt image of the world a coming
together within the organism of a
correct imaging of the world now what do
I mean by corrected vision all I mean is
a provisional image that carries you to
the next moment this is all we can hope
for at this stage
we are much more suited for dancing than
for whatever it is that we have been
doing you know whatever it was it wasn't
dancing we are a part of nature we are a
part of light we are a part of the
energy field of the planet we are not
its keeper in the sense that it is not
given unto us to understand it that was
all a horrible misunderstanding the idea
that we should understand reality and
then somehow make something of it Alfred
North Whitehead said that understanding
is the a perception of pattern as such
as such that's all
so here we have a room full of people
well I it's a pattern it's many patterns
it's the pattern of how men and women
are mixed together statistically as we
scan from left to right if I see a
pattern there I know something about the
crowd I understand something about the
crowd the pattern tells me something and
I call that understanding but we could
analyze the crowd from the point of view
of the distribution of young people and
old people or people in colors in the
red blue spectrum as according to the
yellow white spectrum each one of these
things is a way of analyzing the pattern
in the room and each one of these
patterns tells the perceiver more about
what is going on in the room because the
room is not a distribution of young
people in old people a distribution of
men and women or a distribution of
garment colors the room is a mystery a
recessional mystery that presents itself
as a series of interlocking patterns of
infinite death